the trailer's finally here people so we
are going to
talk about this trailer after we're done
reacting to it and also you know correct
a couple things that i feel dumb for
brain farting on in the last video we
did for godzilla versus kong anywho
let's get into it people
it's more than two seconds
oh god it's already like 10 seconds
so massive
ah
oh fascinating
[Music]
oh
oh damn they're making us allowed to be
like the villain of this
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh damn
this looks great
oh damn that looked awesome yeah
i just want to watch it again right now
holy moly
oh that's a godzilla trailer that's what
i was hoping for
oh man let's talk about it all right so
this is
this is a reaction so this is going to
be the quick thoughts
all right instant thoughts because i
thought it was
really interesting how they composed
this trailer a lot of us have been
making the jokes about how they released
like two
seconds at a time and yet with these
little bits of tv spot footage that
we've been getting you'll still see
these full-on breakdown videos occur
the way they were having like these
series of images unfold and then having
the characters
dialogue sometimes overlapping with one
another but at times it sounded like it
was coming from different scenes
yeah like they're trying to mask some
[ __ ] what [ __ ] are they trying to mask
right now
what thing are they trying to hide
because they have this approach in here
they're kind of touting kong up like
he's going to be the hero because
there's this line that kyle chandler's
it was kyle chandler right
i think it was kyle chandler who does
say that godzilla is attacking people
we don't know why by the end of king of
the monsters they needed godzilla
yeah and then now their godzilla the way
they at least they're setting up this
movie is they need
kong to take out godzilla to fight him
for some reason right godzilla solved
one problem last time but now he's not
on our side anymore he's pissed about
something we don't know about so we need
someone to protect us but they said
something about we don't know why he's
doing it
yeah that leads me to believe that one
little line that like all right so he's
gonna be bad
in the bad guy perspective for a while
but then
perhaps after said winner is declared or
something like that
i mean the way they're setting it up i'm
at the point of impression now that
there might be a definitive winner i'm
curious to know who you guys think it
might be i think there will be a
definitive winner but i don't think
there's going to be a
death between the two of them you know
what i mean about that this morning yeah
like a winner doesn't necessarily mean
that one of them is just obliterated and
will not appear
in a soon-to-be-produced film of some
kind
yeah it seems what they're really honing
in on at least as of this trailer is
that
showbie gene aspect that we talked about
last time because you know
what's funny is in that one we
completely brain farted yeah
i forgot that that was already in king
of the monsters
yeah the whole context the third
generation monarch tweet was already in
there
and then it seems even stronger honed in
on except without the twin quality but
they're applying it to kong here
and that dynamic actually looks like
there'll be a cool
kind of visual storytelling something
without i mean obviously they can't
communicate strictly through words
i like that kind of exchange of like
interacting with animal
community all just about the emotional
body language between their performances
you know and i love those kind of
connective actually we just watched an
episode of doctor who which really honed
in on that
i mean the fight scenes like badass
though they do look bomb i think i
you know especially after seeing this
trailer i think it's safe to say that
the first fight that happens on the navy
spot it's probably godzilla who wins
or at least at a disadvantage he's at a
disadvantage it probably leads to a
thing where they do split apart that is
probably when he grabs like the spinal
plates and then makes the axe out of it
but then they were showing these moments
that looked like they were skull island
history
yeah or do you already have an axe
unless they get back to skull island at
some point or or yeah or maybe
he's been saving this one plate for
years and years and he's finally like i
got a use for this now
good thing i didn't throw this away like
a hoarder yeah
looks like i can't tell if there's just
an editing splice of the footage but
there's this moment where kong is
holding up his axe and then and he's
fighting
some other titans as well because
they've got kong on a boat and they're
transporting him i'm like is there going
to be a prologue to this movie that
takes place
in modern day skull island where we see
the humans arrive
and have a.com how do we get them and
stuff maybe they just show up
mid-battle and they're like cool and all
i know you're doing your dragon
you know punch thing but we're gonna
take his axe take his ass
we can do that but i love the completion
of that shot
with the battle axe of how when he's
going up in the air
and then the atomic breath is guided
directly to the axe
follows with it and then going after him
it's a great looking sequence
i love the way like the nighttime battle
looks and the naval battle sequence
looks as well
and yes we've got other titans here also
i imagine that but with this trailer the
main thing that people will be honing in
on
is why godzilla is attacking people i
have heard the theories
that because they had that post credit
scene at the end of
king of the monsters where they do have
ghidorah's head and then it was
theorized that they're probably going to
make mecha godzilla
i don't think this is going to be
mechagodzilla in disguise
like oh what that was just mechagodzilla
the whole time
some people will probably have that
theory i don't think that's the case hey
maybe somebody has
reverse engineered the orca to make
godzilla angry yeah i
think there's something yeah baby yeah
did you guys catch mechagodzilla okay so
this would be the first time
she's interrupted to actually give me
some solid piece of information here
at like the four second mark see people
running downstairs
and then above here that has to be mecha
godzilla right there
it could i mean i mean that red
underneath his throat and it's
definitely like the
the metal yeah that's okay
so people would believe that that
that makes sense yeah unless it's a
trick of the light or something no that
no it's definitely that's definitely
going to be mechagodz
there was all the there were it was
leaking a while ago
i mean yeah there were things coming out
a while ago that mechagodzilla was going
to be in this made from king ghidorah so
yeah i mean it makes sense that if
people think godzilla's attacking people
then it's actually mecha godzilla yeah
and that means the one winner of this
film will be mechagodzilla so okay so
they're gonna team up to five megahertz
i don't know and godzilla are both going
to lose and mechagodzilla is going to
win
can't they tell the difference with the
cameras that that's not the real console
don't worry i'll have a mission
impossible style mask and voice
modulator to put on
it's cool that they have like this
little bit of a mystery to actually
unpack here with like why is godzilla
attacking people why is he in this bad
guy position
they've got some great looking human
drama that we all look forward to looks
a little more
compelling than before i know i would i
will say not having enjoyed much of the
human side of the last one i did
get a little bit of sense of maybe there
will be a different dynamic and maybe a
different sense of wonder between
that actress whose name i keeper rebecca
hall and the little girl like that was
one where i'm like i don't you know we
don't come to these for a great human
story but you know it would
be nice to have one that's pleasant to
watch while we wait for more monster
fights and that looked like something
that could be cool and that is also
diving into the mythology i also uh
think that fight at the
big the big city and one that they have
with them at night it doesn't
feel a little bit like the first
specific room yeah yeah
oh yeah with all that neon and stuff all
right guys well what did you think
of the godzilla versus kong trailer
leave your thoughts down below
hit that like button who do you think
will win do you think that is
mechagodzilla subscribe click that
notification bell hit the like button
thank god you pointed that out for me
last but not least
i like to give a patreon today shout out
to a man named jt
it's very simple jt you know how i do
with you buddy
godzilla's from japan you're japanese
and you live in hawaii
which means whenever godzilla comes out
inevitably you know
it'll be there pass by you guys and wave
you know not destroy you out right you
win the patron of the day shout out on
one of the biggest trailers ever
just by default of your ethnicity
congratulations
earned it appreciate all the support
you've given over the years i hope 2021
is better than 2020 was for you
keep me updated man miss the hell out of
you hopefully you kick a lot of ass
this year stay asian